متلازمه الهرس شبح جديد يلاحق الاطفال
الناجين هنا في عموم مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
هناك العديد من الاصابات بهذه المرض وهناك
العديد من الاطفال المهددين ببطر الاطراف
نتيجه هذه
الاصابات طبعا نحن الان في مشفى الشفاء
كان من المفترض ان ندخل الى جناح الاطفال
هنا في هذا المشفى ولكن قبل اجراء عمليه
البث هذه لاحظنا ان
الحاله النفسيه للاطفال لا تسمح بتصويرهم
الان يعني الاطفال بصراحه بحاله يرثوا
يعني بحاله يرثى لها بحاله مزريه جدا
نفسيا وجسديا طبعا
الاصابات يعني كثيره في فئه الاطفال هناك
يعني اصابات اخرى
يعني غير جسديه وهي اصابه العائله هناك
العديد من الاطفال الحقيقه فقدوا اهلهم
والى حد هذه اللحظه لا يعلمون انهم فقدوا
اهلهم ولكن يعلمون انهم من الممكن ان ان
يفقدوا اطرافهم نتيجه هذه الاصابات يعني
حقيقه
الالام التي يشعر بها صعبه جدا
هناك العديد من الاصابات التي تحتاج
لاجهزه طبيه متطوره